[Applause]
a trip to chile's high desert is the
perfect excuse to hang with someone
like magdalena she's a shaman
who for a reasonable fee offers up a
soul cleanse
your spirit is healed as your brain
melts
time is an illusion you know that
we all know
after the ceremonial stripping of the
gringo and whatever this
is magdalena forces me to drink
an ungodly amount of water you will
start
a new relation with water so you will be
clean okay then
she burns me
[Music]
into my wounds she pours something
called combo
which is a secretion that comes from a
very poisonous
amazonian tree frog it's done
don't expect anything okay just be here
[Applause]
time is an illusion water is life
and that's when the frog juice really
kicked in
[Music]
there was the desert
it was cruel and then
it was kind
[Music]
there were huge telescopes nestled up
against the heavens
there were strange gurgling pools full
of minerals
there was a bustling city and a chair i
could control with my mind
it was a grand vision of what chile had
to offer
and what needed to be explored
or something like that
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
silicon valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world
but it's being challenged like never
before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet
making things that will blow your mind
my name is ashley vance i'm an author
and journalist
and i'm on a quest to find the most
innovative tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them hello
science says that the atacama desert is
the driest place in the world
the desert plateau is about 10 000 feet
above sea level
the days run extremely hot and the
nights get
extremely cold
it turns out that this hellscape is the
perfect place to build a telescope
between the high altitude and the lack
of moisture in the air
the view of the stars is practically
unobstructed
i'm heading for the atacama large
millimeter array
aka alma the largest astronomical
project
in the world
[Music]
so we're just 500 meters now from the
top of the site
i do feel a little bit light-headed
already
[Music]
almost telescopes sit at nearly 17 000
feet
the same elevation as everest base camp
so it's cold windy and difficult to
breathe
there are dozens of telescopes and it
cost 1.4 billion dollars to build them
all here
in the middle of nowhere with the united
states japan and europe footing most of
the bill
and for that kind of money they didn't
just get a garden variety optical
telescope
they got something special i tracked
down alma's kindly head mechanic
fabiola to get a better understanding of
how this place works
when you're in santiago and you go out
to dinner with somebody how do you
explain to them
how the telescope works um
okay with an optic telescope you look on
the sky
and that's what you see yeah with alma
whatever you don't see with your eyes
whatever is black
that is a lot you see with alma
alma sees in what's known as the
millimeter range of the electromagnetic
spectrum
far beyond the visible range seen by
optical telescopes
and the human eye armed with this
superhuman vision
alma can unveil all kinds of magical
stuff in the universe
that would have been invisible before
to get an idea of what wonders alma is
finding in space
i went to the control center where i met
this very tall man at one time when i
was in graduate school i was
supposedly the tallest astronomer who
had ever lived
the younger generation that was taller
so i'm not sure that's still true
richard simon and his fellow astronomers
are using alma
to look for the origins of stars life
and the universe itself
with alma they're able to see the cosmos
in more detail than ever before
when i was looking at the work that you
guys do you could spot even
a sugar molecule near a star that's
somewhere off in the milky way we can
detect
all kinds of different molecules think
of alma as a huge chemical sniffer
so we can start to understand how stars
form how planets form
how did we wind up with water to support
life
the surreal images alma creates have
revealed earth-like exoplanets
a comet nursery and galaxies at the edge
of the known universe
in the not so distant future they could
also help answer the question
of whether we're not alone one of the
small bones
of saturn enceladus has
geysers of water vapor and other
materials coming out
and it's possible with alma to actually
look at that
and try to see some of the chemistry
that's going on what is inside that moon
what is blasting out into space are
there complicated organic molecules
i suspect that we will learn a lot more
about the chemistry of life
and the possibilities for life in very
strange places
even here in our own solar system
keep watching the skies you beautiful
nerds
it's not all dusty highways and infinite
vistas in the chilean desert
there's big tech and big fun to be had
as well
and to find the fun you just need to
look for the oasis
the town of san pedro de aracama
this is one of the world's most remote
tourist hot spots
[Music]
a magnet for dirty hippies and chilled
out dogs
[Music]
why would anyone choose to vacation at 8
000 feet in the desert
well there are glorious geysers that
demand to be roamed
there are sand dunes to surf
[Music]
and there are huge watering holes that
no one can explain
[Music]
oddly enough there's big business out in
the atacama too
more solar radiation reaches this desert
than anywhere else in the world
this makes it the perfect place to build
massive solar panel farms
if you stop by for a visit they'll put
you to work washing the panels
how's my technique it's good
the tricky thing about solar energy is
that it needs to be stored
like that
[Music]
and the atacama happens to have an
answer for that too
chile is one of the world's leading
producers of lithium
the stuff that goes into all of our
smartphone laptop and electric car
batteries
and to see how lithium is pulled from
the earth i went to visit the operations
of the mining giant
sqm hello ashley how you doing finally
here
my guide through the minds is alejandro
bucher
he's a cheerful engineer who has spent
years working in the great void
when i think of something like a
lithium-ion battery in a laptop
or even a tesla with thousands of
batteries
it's what like a spoonful of lithium
that would
go into those batteries you would say in
an ipad or in a cell phone
you could have something like a spoonful
in a car you could have maybe
10 to 15 kilos of lithium
it's the nearby andes mountains that
make these mines possible
over millions of years minerals from the
mountains leach into the ground
then they collect together and form huge
salt beds
rich in lithium sulfate potassium and
boron
companies like sqm pump water up through
the beds
and store the mineral-rich liquid in
large ponds
from there it's up to the sun to do its
thing and evaporate away the water
leaving the minerals and salt behind
and nowhere evaporates better than chile
now we are heading for the first part of
the pond operation
[Applause]
[Music]
there's a lot of ponds
those are pretty
[Applause]
[Music]
as this is the first pond you can see
the salts
forming in the surface
yeah it's gotta be crazy because you
already have the harsh
heat and cold and then you have all this
salt just blowing around
everything these pickup trucks suffer a
lot but the other equipment
uh we made them from a special steel
that really works good here
and now we're moving to the lithium
ponds that are only two
of the 44 million square meters that we
have here
[Music]
this bond we made it so we can
experience
what is a little brine when we have it
in the big ponds we we cannot sample it
so we made this little pond what exactly
is this stuff
this is magnesium chloride magnesium
chloride
is a magnesium that we need to get rid
of for being able to produce the lithium
in the plant okay
we will only send on the track the
liquid just the liquid just the liquid
okay so this is lithium
what are the odds that some part of this
is in my smartphone i couldn't guarantee
it but it's
pretty sure that almost hundred percent
sure that
part of your smartphone went through
this bond at some point in the past
at some point this is smartphone
smartphone juice
wow
you guys must be excited that tesla's
are selling well and that everybody's
getting into
watching cars now it's very interesting
but it puts a lot of pressure on us
so we will more than double our capacity
probably in four years
chile may have the largest lithium
deposits in the world
but it started to fall behind countries
like australia and china when it comes
to production
and in china it's a one-stop shop with
the mining and battery production
happening together
[Music]
this is a leap chilean companies have
been unwilling to take
maybe you could make the batteries here
in chile well for me it would be
excellent but
the company we're experts in hybrid
geology we're expert in mining we're
exporting producing lithium
if we put us to produce batteries we're
probably not going to do it well
things have been extra tense lately
between the mines and the chilean
government
the feds have put strict quotas on
lithium production
and they've also been trying to act
tough and save face after some politicos
were accused
of taking bribes from the mines
[Music]
environmentalists aren't huge fans of
the mines either
they say that water is being sucked from
nearby lagoons
that feed these flocks of stunning
flamingos
what we do here has absolutely no impact
to the flamingos but we're still
responsible
what's happening with them we need to do
counting of the flamingos every year
they identify them by the feathers on
the tail
so they they can differentiate every
flamingo
the miners here work for a week and then
take a week off because of the dry hot
salty conditions
but there are some on the job perks the
sunsets here
are everyday amazing you have all these
different colors that
only women know the names
every day and you don't get tired of
that
it's really beautiful
alejandro has a point not so much about
the colors that only women
apparently know but about the beauty of
the minds
these odd marvels make the modern world
let tesla's flamingo breeding program
begin
[Music]
chileans like to hold santiago up as a
symbol of everything they've done right
it's orderly and prosperous
and there's all that you would want from
a capital city clinging to the bottom of
the globe
[Music]
sure you can get roped into the
occasional karikari
but here they say it's more refined and
nothing says refinement
like a foot long coney mayonnaise
definitely a questionable choice
[Music]
this capital built with mineral wealth
and struggling with its fallout
is looking for new ways to survive in a
changing environment
[Music]
in
[Music]
pino figured out how to make water from
air with the touch of a button
hector made a fortune as an engineer but
now works full-time on his freshwater
system
what propelled you to think up this
project
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
so you use this machine at home yes okay
and and your daughter uses this every
day ah they complete my family
[Music]
sees this technology having uses far
beyond his family
his freshwater machine feeds off
humidity in the air
it pulls in water particles through a
vent and then basically forms a rain
cloud inside the machine
a series of filters purify the water
collect it
and then pristine h2o flows out of the
faucet
[Music]
so i can drink it yeah i tried it
[Music]
it's no problem
right now one magic water machine costs
about 1600 bucks
but he wants to shrink the price and its
size to something like a backpack
as he perfects the design he's installed
his machines in chile's dry north
[Music]
impact
distilled the idea for fresh water
inside an incubator
funded by some of santiago's wealthiest
people
it's called the idea factory or if
for those into the whole brevity thing
they support
tech with a do-gooder bent politicians
stop by to schmooze
kids get a chance to learn it's not a
factory designed to build the next
google or facebook
it focuses on things for chile and south
america
and they've got hyper local branches
hidden in unexpected corners of santiago
there are tech incubators all over the
world but you won't find many
in a neighborhood like this if has
another building here
that's been set up to inspire local
youngsters and give budding inventors
a helping hand
[Music]
here in recoleta things are a bit more
lively than in palo alto
and it suits the place i showed up on a
demo day
when kids from the neighborhood pour
through the gates to check out ifs
gadgets
there was plenty of eye candy but
nothing beat this
hello robots it's like every other video
conferencing robot
on a stick but this one is basically
lethal
that's so cool
all of the gadgets come from this man
rodrigo quevedo
he's something of a local celebrity and
has kanye west's levels of passion
[Music]
rodrigo was an officer in the chilean
army and then an engineer
until he had a revelation and became a
robotics entrepreneur
his most inspired invention is this
wheelchair people can control it by
tilting their head
or making a gesture soon roderigo hopes
it'll move by thought alone
by reading impulses from a brainwave
[Music]
rodrigo's helpers were surprisingly
gentle as they gave me the power
of telekinesis
[Music]
that's how i turn it on three blinks
it's like a genie
[Music]
uh
oh my god that's crazy it's amazing
it's fussy
[Music]
and that was the perfect ending to a
magical trip
chile will always have a special place
in my subconscious
[Music]
when i close my eyes at night i can
still hear my shaman magdalena
singing and see her desert compound
she scarred me but you know
in a good way
[Music]
of all my trips around the world this
year this one was a proper adventure
there's a mystical quality to chile and
it only gets more profound as your body
dries out
and your brain loses oxygen
as for the tech chile has the big stuff
down
it has embraced the weirdness of the
land and tried to make the most out of
it
if the startups in santiago can tap into
that same spirit then chile has a bright
future ahead
either that or the poison really got to
[Music]
me